[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we asked what's it like
inside NASA yes and we should know
because we've been inside NASA Houston
we have a problem we've let rhett and
Link inside yeah you know the saying
houston we have a problem
well that's because if you're in space
and you have a problem you tell houston
and that's where we were in Houston at
the at the Space Center there the
Johnson Space Center yeah
they graciously invited us and gave us a
tour what I learned some stuff yeah I
feel like you I feel like the wheels are
really turning for you
so I really want to know what came with
that because we never discuss it because
we move right up we had to do a show
that night right so um we will dedicate
this episode to unpacking NASA's secrets
but yeah we were the secrets that
they're willing to disclose to anyone
from the public who comes inside we're
but we are fresh off of a little mini
tour we were in Houston for for our
comedy show and went to shout out to
Houston New Orleans Birmingham
Jacksonville and Tampa we had some fun
on on some on all those stages all those
stages all those stages it's like a
stage 5 rocket yeah and you know what
we're not done with the fun while we're
talking about that we okay you've
actually got again this is just we're
not planning on touring much in the near
future after this to go take a pretty
good break from that so this is the last
chance to see this particular show for a
good while yeah just this fall of 2019
just go to red link live.com but to whet
your appetite first of all we've got a
week of special McCall it a special
thing
called the Blue Creek conversationally
Creek conversations where around the
launch of the novel we're planning a
very very special evening in Boston New
York Chicago Dallas Fort Worth two shows
in winston-salem North Carolina and then
back here in Los Angeles and that goes
from October 27th through November 1st
November 3rd I'm sorry and then we're
doing more of our musical comedy show in
Albuquerque Phoenix Sacramento and
Valley Center California November 20th
through 23rd so go to red link live.com
to get tickets but um we did have some
fun we didn't bring the kids this time
Britain Britain was still there yeah it
was he's a kid he's 19 yeah well
technically he isn't oh and let me I do
want to clarify it because I want to say
it every time we talk about the Bleak
Creek conversations that you get a copy
of the novel when you get that ticket so
think about that it's a deal Kay as
you're considering coming out to that
and we're showing a documentary that we
shot it back home and buoy screen North
Carolina over the summer so it's gonna
be an intimate one-of-a-kind evening and
then for these shows I mean I really
think we're stretching our legs like we
did we had some crazy let some crazy
moments with with fans I want to give a
shout out to you guys for for for being
so supportive and letting us talk about
whatever we want to talk about we don't
even know what's gonna happen which I'm
like soil eatin fish remember soil eatin
fish that was one night right we talked
extensively about that
another night we talked and I can't even
explain it
you had to be there well that's the
thing is that the each each show ends up
being different we don't we have some
things that we say before songs that we
always say but the even that changes up
but we use we use the the energy and the
vibe of that particular location and
sometimes it's yes and we're channels of
Voodoo of New Orleans we saw some voodoo
dolls we got to tell this story that we
told from stage we were in this place
because you and Britain are like into
all this type of stuff and it turns out
voo
dolls are supposed to be nice they're
supposed to be mostly used for positive
purposes oh who do as a whole voodoo as
a whole which okay I'm probably gonna
get some things wrong so let me just
give that disclaimer you're not an
expert I'm not an expert shouldn't be
but I've been to the Voodoo Museum in
New Orleans and that has given me enough
of an authority to say that
voodoo is like a meeting of you know
predominantly African ancestral
religions meets some elements of Western
religion like Catholicism and kind of
it's so sort of a hybrid sort of comes
out yeah and that's what you end up
ended up having in in New Orleans in the
Northlands area but I think that
culturally we tend to be kind of
fascinated with what we see as like the
subversive maybe we would say evil side
of Voodoo cuz it's like witchcraft and
spells and sacrificing a doll so that
you can hurt somebody but in reality uh
most of that stuff the intention of it
is is always good like you said to bring
good to someone but yeah sometimes you
might want to bring some bad to somebody
but but I'll tell you what you can't do
is you can't roll into one of these
voodoo shops and take a picture of the
voodoo dolls they won't let you do that
so we're walking around it says no
photos no photos and I heard a girl come
up to Rhett and it was it turned out to
be two girls and I was a little further
away but I did hear the entire
conversation and but do you want to tell
it since you said it to you yeah well
for those of you who haven't been in New
Orleans before it doesn't matter what
time of year it is a lot of times there
are just people everyone is what time of
day yeah cuz this was like one o'clock
everyone is walking around with large
beverage containers of different sizes
and shapes often very tall like the one
that this girl had was big as her head
thirty six inches tall this giant she
had a cleansing install head cup full of
alcohol who knows what a lot of times
it's just a doll but yes
slushee I mean they got whole bars that
behind the bar instead of seeing like
taps
it's just alcoholic slushies yeah for
the children and so she comes up and
she's already a little bit New Orleans
and she sees me and she says oh and then
she sees link kind of behind me she's
like oh
aren't you guys Thomas and Rhett and I
joined the conversation at this point in
order to say why yes well yes yeah well
the interesting thing is we've gotten
mistaken Thomas and Rhett that we've
been called lots of things Thomas Rhett
is a country country music I think for
most if you do not know that so that's
what makes this particularly funny
because she was getting in her mind the
only Rhett that she knew was Thomas
Rhett so that aren't you Thomas in red
that's the best that's the best one
we've ever gotten
yeah and then she took a picture and
then the guy who worked there is no
Berkshires and we're like well she's
taking a picture of us Thomas and Rhett
yeah it was she's not taking don't you
know who we are of your voodoo doll she
certainly does
they had a glass case with a paper mache
head in it and then they had a newspaper
clipping that's like this head had been
found somewhere but it was clearly paper
mache yeah right I don't know if that
was a recreation but I think it's just
all part of it part of the act so we did
that
oh and we ate this is also New Orleans
where we ate lunch I had I had a
spiritual experience
I mean you wait in line and then you you
order at the counter and they're like
frying chicken and fried fish and shrimp
and chicken was the special everyone was
getting like it was like a meeting three
type of safe situation to get you're
meeting your three veg sides three
veggies but I think it was - it wasn't
mean - okay and you know I'm like well I
kind of want some shrimp I like a good
fried shrimp at a place like this I
ordered that but all you guys got the
fried chicken it did look very good but
I did this place was called I wanted to
say Marjorie's but it wasn't it was made
with no our major E's commerce
restaurant a lot of locals in there and
when you're up there getting ready to
order it seems like chaos and no matter
what we did it seems like we were always
doing the wrong thing it's just like she
would yell at us I come over here so I
got you what have you ordered it's like
well know what can you order what do you
want and it was like the the taking of
the orders was like there was an
aggressive frustrations dance and I was
like you know what this feels right you
know if you're going into a place where
you see I mean I saw a guy who looked
like he was on meth I saw a guy who
looked like he could have been the mayor
of New Orleans they were both there
eating at tables he can fry eating the
same fried chicken what if the mayor of
New Orleans is on this oh well let's
let's assume not okay I'm just saying
there was like a politician dude and you
know it's just um it was a melting pot
of locals and then we just felt constant
shame for doing everything wrong I'm
like this is how you should feel you
know you're in the right place when you
feel like you're screwing it all up
well when Britain sat down after being
through that line that was a very stress
inducing experience yeah and it was
because you just felt like an outsider
but then it was replaced with the pure
joy dining experience
shrimp were amazing the they had these
twice but they caught him twice baked
potatoes but they scooped it out just
like mashed potatoes and put gravy on it
still it was amazing right um
no skins there was no skins on the twice
baked potatoes and corn and I'm going
through this shrimp like there's no
tomorrow
loving it you guys are saying the
chickens amazing I look over and I see
half a chicken leg uneaten on Britain's
plate and I'm like we're blood you done
with that chicken leg are you gonna eat
that he's like you can have it I took a
bite of that chicken leg it's the best
chicken I was transported to my nanny's
Sunday after church kitchen table where
she would always fry up chicken she fro
man I got goosebumps and then I started
talking about how good this chicken was
and I got my goose buzz I got goose
bumps I got goose bump bump
and it just felt so good to eat that
chicken it was chicken it was the best
fried chicken who I've ever had I mean I
can say fried chicken like I haven't had
better fried chicken to that maybe
there's a time that I've forgotten that
I had as good a fried chicken but the
ratio of Chris penis on the outside to
juiciness on the inside and of course
I'm a white meat man and a lot of people
are turned off by white meat because
they don't they think that it's dry and
they think that a breast is dry yeah but
I think that the breast is the perfect
piece of chicken because it's the most
chicken concentrated without any
hindrance of bone it's just does you
have a giant you don't give as much of
that crunchy and that skin I like that
too
you get a huge blanket of skin man it's
like I got it you got your ration not a
filtration of skin and meat on the bird
it's like the place that you're intended
to take a bite out of a bird if you just
to pick up a bird you would just take a
bite out of it I'm a dark meat man but I
mean listen but hold on but he was so
juicy it didn't matter that it would
turn a dark meat man into a white meat
man no I didn't let you have any because
I wasn't gonna give any up but Britain
did thank goodness and it was absolutely
transformative I mean it Trant it was
transported if it transported me and my
because my name is not able to fry
chicken anymore and she had she you know
there's something to the brining like if
it's really salty you're on to something
yeah well they gotta get there's the
brining does something something with
milk with the juiciness that did
something with bryon milk or something
but it's apparently a replicable until
this place major ease and highly
recommended if you're in New Orleans oh
yeah it was just it was so good I mean
now we'll say well you know we were good
because speaking of food we were doing
the the child down in your town thing
that we did we do before each show where
we take the two things that are
recommended us recommended to us on
Twitter and we pit them against each
other and I can't even remember what the
New Orleans recommendations were that's
how it was gonna it was uh that was
gumbo and gumbo and beignets
it was beignets from cafe du Mall which
is the place to get beignets but they
had been in the bag for maybe 45 minutes
by the time they got to us and you
really need he throws fresh they still
won we thought the gumbo was should have
been jambalaya and we were trying to
figure out why it wasn't red but it was
Yannick we were just super ignorant
about what jambalaya is versus gumbo and
gumbo because of the roux he's supposed
to be brown but I just don't I mean it
wasn't bad I had an entire like you know
yup I mean an entirety of something says
nothing about it right that's what I'm
saying
it was it was edible but it wasn't like
I have to tell someone about this so
they will also eat it which is what I
would do with the fried chicken yeah I
don't like the plate unless it's
lickable you lick the plate because I'm
hungry I'm always hungry it's edible I'm
hungry right now not just ate and then
we went to an escape room you know it's
like a Miami
am I wrong am I wrong to say that escape
rooms are not like a hotbed of coolness
it's like you just don't think you'd
like but what is I'm sure the coolness
like give me an example like a rock and
roll bar like out back in the alley like
if you're walking in the back alley and
you see like I don't know you see
anybody from motley crue baby in a
movies escape rooms are kind of like I
don't know if we're is that what you're
saying yeah it's kind of it's kind of
well and then it's it's like you got
this grand idea we're gonna put people
in a room they're gonna solve these
problems but there gets it it's gonna be
immersive and you're like you're gonna
you're gonna forget where you are it's
gonna be like Disneyland but you never
quite forget that you're in a strip mall
right and like it's hard an old
converted office building yeah it's hard
to make the set dressing work that well
in what used to be a dental office right
but we had a great time
now escaping a dental office hey maybe
that's a win-win maybe that's what we
should do just acquire a dental office
and just block it
put some clues in there you got to pull
pull some teeth
to get some keys I could get with that
the one in Tampa was it was pretty fun
though it was like it was zombie
apocalypse and I'm like I don't want to
do this if there's like people dressed
as zombies I just I'm not I don't want
to have to have that type of interaction
but as soon as you went in the place we
knew there wasn't gonna be anybody
dressed as anything it's just gonna be
some faint sound effects of zombies
outside and we are inside tasks with
developing me unlocking the antidote for
the zombie apocalypse yeah pretty cool
actually I we had a lot of fun yeah we
did we didn't get in and we didn't fight
too much and we got out and you and I
didn't fight anything I think Britain
and I fought
which i think is a that's a great I
think that's the dynamic when Britain's
there it's like is that is that what
happens like you know I started to get
grumpy after a couple of days on the
road and I'm like yeah I think he's
there too
he's there to absorb that he absorbs
your grumpiness I direct it towards him
sometimes you did you observe do you
observe my absorption his absorption
yeah I mean I actually think that his uh
he changes the dynamic of spending that
much time together on the road yeah
because I think that we talked about
this on this past trip which apparently
I lost my voice on the trip because I
needed you need a hack somewhere no it's
yeah I've got like a you mean to cut the
throat of your voodoo dog give you a
little tracheotomy I've got like a like
a constant production of phlegm that's
just like it hasn't been happening until
until right now well it started
happening with me yesterday and I think
it's so it's a return to Los Angeles
there's something in the air here the
pollution yeah something I'm serious I
know well I know there's a lot of my
nose started running a little bit more
my throat felt a little congested
well I guess I'm gonna be struggling
with it all time we should move to
Arizona
I mean know what I was gonna say oh he
changes the dynamic because when we
spend a lot of time together on the road
first of all
our work responsibilities back here
don't go away now we've got a great team
and there's not a whole lot on a
day-to-day basis that we have to worry
about anymore from a company standpoint
but there's still a lot of things and
then Jenna is there she's getting a lot
of email she's handling a lot of things
asking us a lot of questions we made the
observation that we don't get a lot done
other than touring even though that the
act of getting ready for the show you
know signing the posters for the
meet-and-greet and then meeting some you
know meeting some of the mythical
society people or anybody else that
might be in that town that we've
arranged a meet and then you do the show
and then you got the meeting to be after
I mean now that's all the work work that
we do but there it's a pretty
emotionally draining and so if you're
gonna do something else you want it to
be like something that can kind of be
engaging like going and eating fried
chicken or going to an escape room we
did get out by the way
yeah which apparently only 35% of people
who go into this escape room get out and
I gotta say that's what she told us can
make you feel good about you think that
she they're lying about the escape
percentage that makes absolute there's
no you I can't think of zero reason why
they would lie about that I just think
people if people don't escape aren't
they angry I've been to an escape room
before not gotten out and aren't they
still in there when the time's up they
just let you out let's say you're a
failure yeah it escape rooms you didn't
escape room that's only escaped from
escape room would not be fun for people
who like escape rooms if people who are
coming to an escape room for the first
time always get out that seems pretty
straightforward to me because yeah yeah
and we had very motivated we were all
very motivated and we all worked well
together and then Britain and his
friends have been to an escape room like
the day before so they were kind of
primed there's a there's only so many
different ways you can hide a key in a
box you know what I'm saying they had
some pretty cool ins it was very cool
but we wouldn't you know it wasn't cool
because you know I don't think it gonna
be
not cool it's it's like it's like magic
without a magician
it's kind of what it feels like it
sounds like you're doing all the magic
but it's just puzzles
that's an interesting perspective I
don't know it feels like it's in the
same genre even though there's no magic
involved you think people who like magic
also like escape rooms yeah big overlap
there I that make sense to me I can't
exactly explain why but I agree with it
but we got out so we are in the top 35
of all people top 35 top 35 people where
that top 35 people on the planet because
we escaped from a skate room in Tampa
Florida where yeah we're in the top 35
percent of people who have escaped a
very particular escape room in Tampa and
I got to be honest with you nothing is
tamper nothing in gets any place in the
world but when I found out that 35% of
people had made it out of this escape
room in Tampa I was like I'm gonna feel
pretty bad about myself if I don't if I
don't qualify it in the top 35 percent
hmm I mean that's just kind of pride
that's how much pride I have and I was
like especially with the team that we've
got here I feel like this is gonna
happen we don't have any strangers no
randos sometimes you get randos in your
group that's bad I had a drunk Rando
the only time I've never gotten out of I
didn't get out of a skate room is
because there was a very distracting
drunk Rando in the room with us hated
that guy at a certain point I remember
you told me you just kind of have to
turn to him and say do you couldn't take
any sit in a corner could take no
direction it's in the corner man he's
such a distraction in the corner and
make sure you're not sitting on anything
like a key a lock or a clue right so we
went to NASA more questions than answers
perhaps let's get to those but first
let's ask you to buy stuff mythical
dot-com has all types of stuff for sale
including this shirt but no you know
link it does but it doesn't have that
shirt this shirt that shirt is available
at amazon.com slash mythical because
that's the whole point of this ad shoot
I blew it is to blow is to let you
remember that amazon.com slash mythical
has t-shirts
on demand that you cannot get at
mythical calm so don't even try it
don't listen to me and you know if
you're in those prime K prime is that
stuff prime prime eligible so if you if
you're Prime member go over there and do
it free shipping all that amazon.com /
mythical man check it all out check it
all out
we seem tired right now
yeah I mean I am tired I'm sleepy
because we went on tour I feel like I'm
not giving my best work but we just
podcast sex is that what you're saying
well I mean I think I don't know I want
to lean into this because I think this
is this is just let's go tired at heart
part of an ear biscuit is is an
authentic like hey with this where it's
checking in one sense okay having a
conversation real in the current state I
mean I'm in this state where I've got
phlegm that is being produced in
changing the character of my voice and
then I have to do that and then get it
back to normal
I just don't think people want to know
that if we had a choice we wouldn't be
doing this right now i you you are
putting words in my mouth I'm not saying
I don't know I'll do this I'm just being
honest it of what I'm saying is that do
you want to do this right now I
definitely want to do it I want to lean
into it the whole point of what I'm
saying is that okay to do it it's a
privilege to do this it's unusual for us
to go on tour and then to come back like
we we were gone we were gone over the
weekend and then even though we
typically try to get back and then the
day we get back we have like a day off
because we're trying to let replicate
the weekend we couldn't do that
yesterday because we had to get on get
on the phone with the guy who is reading
our audible book and kind of go through
and answer some questions which was fun
it was fun but then when I'm struggling
kind of continued on with the day and
now we got up today and we started with
like very business ii corporate stuff
right from the beginning and then we had
to go do an interview the people came
here to do the interview that was also
for the audible thing and then we
stepped right into here after about a
10-minute lunch so that's where you're
preaching you're not complaining you're
just saying no I'm just saying that like
typically we would have had a chance
like we haven't talked about the fact
that we went to NASA no we haven't
so now we're going to talk about the
fact that we went to NASA and what that
did for us I mean I don't have any
agenda here I used to use a moon landing
you said that I've got a memory up the
moon landing doesn't have to be faked
that's not what we're getting at yeah we
did except we were humbled to accept the
offer to go to Johnson Space Center and
so we pull up there of course there's a
gate you know they have security you
just don't want to roll in there and
start kicking over rockets you know you
got to be with the right people they
give tours like via a tram cuz I saw
that yeah oh we got walked around and
John water came up and filmed it for us
and it's gonna be some of this is gonna
make it into a video piece on LTAC right
at a later date we ate some astronaut
food and that's the main point of of
that video that we shot there so that
was really cool
but we should probably talk about some
some of the other aspects of it
well the I had no idea what to expect
and the first thing that we went in was
it was called the vehicle just like the
space vehicle mock-up center or
something like that big ol room and all
of a sudden is like like multi wheeled
vehicles I mean that didn't look like
the Mars rover just all different types
of things that they were building like
they had this thing that had six wheels
but then it had a torso and the like
Hannah's arms I think had four wheels of
a like a person I called as a I called
it the the redneck centaur yeah because
it was an ATV on the bottom and a man up
top now I think that they there's
there's a competition series where
people build different things like she
notices foster students to foster
innovation and I think we were looking
at some of those things but the main
thing that I was thinking no this room
is absolutely massive it's probably
longer than a football field and maybe
as wide as this giant couple
cranes that can move up and down almost
like you're a shipyard you know to be on
pick up these giant pieces of equipment
and it has everything from a full scale
not a kind of a replica of the
International Space Station when the
different modules kind of connected
together and then it has all those
prototypes and prototype vehicles that
link was talking about the competition
vehicles that can do things like throw a
basketball through hoop and stuff that
the student engineering students have
done there are rock through the moon and
then it has like part of the shuttle
like the practice part of the shuttle so
let's hop it up this let's talk about
this okay so it's it's literally the
Space Shuttle cockpit that they built to
put the astronauts into train yeah but
you don't need the whole shuttle you
just need the front of it and so we
climb up in that thing of course the
Space Shuttle is not they don't use that
they don't use the Space Shuttle anymore
the things that they're doing now are
that they're sending there's two
different types of missions they're
sending people to Mars and then they're
sending people to the moon and the
people that they're sending to what
which one is like almost they call a
commercial travel right yeah I didn't I
got to be honest with you I didn't
understand exactly what they were
talking about every time they said then
they're just gonna start sending people
people who want to go and can just get
on the thing is that was your time at
like Richard Branson was talking about
yes maybe we should have asked some more
questions talk about it but the Space
Shuttle they don't use that anymore
Space Shuttle is is obsolete but they
still got the front of the cockpit in
there and so we climbed up in this thing
I mean we got to sit on the toilet the
it's like got a suction lever yeah it
sucks the poop right out of you well
it's is it in the right direction yeah
once you once you get the poop out it
sucks it down so if you just poop in the
open air and
space I mean there's no gravity
newsflash so it sucks the poop and the
pee which I'm thinking about getting one
of those installed in my house because
better be safe than sorry I mean the
flush kind of does the same thing on
earth yeah just saying and then we we
crawled into the the cockpit two seats
up there and here's the thing ma'am back
when they first built this stuff and
used it apparently everything needed its
own dedicated button like we live in a
world now when it's like you got this
little screen and then everything like
everything that you want to do is all
within the screen right you know it's
like but then it was it was just buttons
levers knobs and if they were really
important that you have to lift
something up in order to then push the
button but every single square inch of
real estate inside of this cockpit just
buttons well I think one of the things
that I was struck with so overwhelming
is and this is a combination of seeing
the inside of what they would actually
have to fly seeing the cockpit meeting a
couple of astronauts you know we met
Matthew who we did the tasting with and
then we met the the retired astronaut
and his wife who they're their grandkids
are big mythical beasts I was just
struck with how much they have to know
well yeah first of all you got to know
what every button does and you got to
know where it is
I guess you start to associate like the
physical location of the thing and like
after what and that's why they have this
thing there so you can train it like
second nature you just know where to go
for these buttons well and they have
contact I mean theoretically I guess you
can lose contact but you do have contact
with the ground with Houston so you're
gonna get there they're monitoring
things and getting feedback and they're
gonna be able to like tell you what you
need to to do maybe tell you what button
to press but you know when we talked to
Matthew he was like coming off of his
basically finishing his training to
become an astronaut and he was like
going into his geology class yeah
because you have to when you go up there
yeah there's so few people are up there
and you have to know so much more
because you you you just can't send a
specialist for everything you can't send
a doctor just to have a doctor you know
it's not like but they they demand they
do send doctors but they're doctors who
are also astronauts who have been
trained in all these other ways but but
he said not usually they don't send
doctors because you got it you got to
have this breadth of knowledge that goes
beyond that well I guess what I'm saying
is if you were a doctor you you had a
medical background you would then have
to have all the other same training to
be able to physically do what astronauts
do right and to mentally do what
astronauts do and I asked him yeah cuz
he's like you said he had taken he had
just finished a two-week course in
geology and you asked him what else he
had studied well he was like you know
I've got dental dental care I can
extract the tooth I was like did you
pull somebody's tooth for training he
was like no I was like what dude he
didn't go all the way pull it you got to
pull your own tooth but here's the thing
that kind of struck right now crazy is
that yeah you know there's 13 astronauts
in the current class and so I asked him
how many people applied for those 13
positions
he said 18,000 yeah so if you think
about the selection list like when you
meet somebody who's an NBA player I
don't know what the percentages are of
like the number of people who want to be
in the NBA in the number of people who
are but it's an elite thing but it's
somebody who's really good at basketball
which is impressive in and of itself but
it's still basketball I mean like yeah
there there's no indications that
they're gonna be good at everything else
but an astronaut has gotten you know
they have gone through this evaluation
to test their physical capabilities
their mental capabilities their
emotional stability they have psych
evals because you're going to go up and
you're going
be in this confined space and you can't
go nuts you can't be difficult to you
can't be hard to get along with
you can't not play well with others you
have to be the kind of person who can be
a leader but it also can be a follower
here's the fact high school senior
players eventually drafted by an NBA
team about three and ten thousand or
0.03 percent chance but again that's
still talking about somebody played
basketball this is someone who has been
through this incredibly stringent
application process who is like the best
human the best humans we can come up
with to send away from Earth were
sending the best of them away well I
would I would say the most well-rounded
technically you don't think they're the
best I don't know my best is kind of a
catch-all term it's a little too generic
okay I consider them the best the best
of the best
I'm he he said that anybody can apply
it's a government position you just go
to the website I want to be an astronaut
calm but how many people who go through
that process I would say the vast
majority of people who go through the
process of application I'll probably
have some reason to think that they're
qualified but that got me to thinking
about you've got these people more and
more people are going to be going and
the qualification isn't gonna be coming
down I think that I thought well
commercial travel I don't agree with
that because they said that there were
gonna be maybe like 40 different people
in space in the next X number of years
and so there was gonna be more
astronauts but I don't think that when
you take the top 13 if you expanded the
top 13 out to the top 50 I think the
drop off from number 13 number 50 in a
group that small is not going to be that
measurable
I think we're certain up a certain top
percentage of these people are going to
be in the incredible most incredible
people that Earth has to offer
now here's what I was thinking and this
gets into ethics and other things but
like
shouldn't those people shouldn't those
people be the ones who are doing the
sperm donation oh I thought you're gonna
say run for president doing the sperm
donation what are you referring to
shouldn't we talk shouldn't they be the
ones to do to do the sperm donation for
everyone i well you don't want only
their seed or eggs I might add right
shouldn't they shouldn't we be trying to
create a massive I know I don't want to
get into that kind of maybe I am maybe
I'm I've stepped in it by accident I'm
just saying that if you want to make all
choice for Rhett 1:1 John asked me for
sperm I just think that the sperm at the
sperm banks could be a lot better if we
were making astronauts just add to it
they don't have to go in it doesn't have
to be all astronauts sperm because you
don't want everybody to look like the
few number of people who are astronauts
I think you should be able to get your
hands on some astronaut sperm if you
need it if you want it I guess what I'm
saying is is I think that astronauts
should be required to have a certain
number of samples to the sperm banks
it's like if you're gonna go through
this trouble first of all you have to
donate sperm before you go up because
once you go up your DNA is all
compromised because of solar radiation
yeah seriously your DNA changes and your
telomeres drinkers you said yeah I had
to do with like the physical lack of
pressure and weightlessness first of all
your head swells we were told about that
yeah well not only their face swells up
your nasal your nasal passages become
completely blocked when you're in space
you don't you have a sense of smell fart
it up okay so one of the reasons and
again we're probably going to retread
some of this when we show this video but
on elta but one of the reasons that a
lot of the food that the astronauts want
is spicy like they like like wasabi and
hot sauce and that kind of thing is
because they can't taste anything
because they can't smell
you taste with just your mouth and I was
instantly underrated I was like this
sounds absolutely miserable any and then
that was when Matthew said well the
thing that you don't want to get is you
don't want to get a cold in space
because when you have a cold on earth
gravity is working to drain your your
clogged nasal passages and you're
swallowing it or coughing it up or
whatever but gravity is constantly
moving it out when you don't have
gravity it can actually become a serious
situation when you've got a cold and
you're producing all this extra fluid
and mucus and it's just staying in your
head and and they they don't give them
like any sort of light you couldn't just
give them nasal spray indefinitely
because it's it's it's the effect of the
head swelling effect is so large that
you can't really counteract it with
drugs long-term so he said that's one of
the main reasons why astronauts have an
isolation period before they go up
because if you put a group of people in
an isolate in an isolated place and you
don't let it be contaminated with the
cold virus or uh virus in general for a
certain amount of time as long as you
keep that group of people isolated they
cannot become sick that I it seems so
obvious to me cannot become sick at all
if you take four people cuz they want to
send four people to the moon by 2024 hey
I didn't realize that's what he was
saying yeah and you can use in you I
refuse to believe that you put them in a
room yeah and you say we're gonna make
sure that none of you have a cold but
we're gonna get you tested and then
we're gonna isolate you and you're gonna
have no contact with your face like you
can talk to your like wife behind like a
glass you'll be in a you'll be in an
aquarium then when we walk you out to
the get into the lunar module hold your
breath we're gonna isolate you the whole
time
so that you cannot get sick now it is
conceivable that sometime in the process
of like putting on putting on the suit
or somebody involved in the process ends
up transmitting the virus to you but the
plan is is that people who are on space
missions don't have any viruses can
cause them to get sick or bad
teria i guess and this is quite a
protocol to this because you got you
know the International Space Station
which we met a guy I wish I could
remember his name I think even gave us a
business card and then his grandkids
came to the show yeah great guy was it
bill I have his business card or in my
suitcase at home but he spent a hundred
and ninety days on the International
Space Station with one other drush
endued yep and they they trained for
years together to be up there and I was
like so did you like each other and he
was like yeah we were we're grip buddies
because we trained so much together you
know they they hit it off and they keep
in touch and they'll like still get
together every year there's like this
space explorers Academy and convention
well and you have to have orbited the
earth 100 times to qualify for it yes so
if you've orbited the earth 99 times
you're not invited to you can be out
front like in an info one more time
I want the buffet but the funny thing
about your work at the buffet they let
him in so we were talking to his wife
and his daughter and his wife said he
would call me every single day because
apparently there is a phone in the
International Space Station that can
call any landline or any line on earth
at any time and he was up there in late
in 2006/2007 yeah and he said that he
would call her every single day and she
said every single night when he was
about to go to know it yeah when he was
about to go to bed but good but he was
on they operate on Greenwich Mean Time
so it was like 3:00 in the afternoon
wherever he would want to start talking
that was interesting just to look these
little things that I learned that I'd
never thought about astronauts who were
in orbit operate on Greenwich Mean Time
and why wouldn't they right you got to
pick something because your your
position it's it's day and night means
nothing when you're up there because
you're going around I don't know how
many times you'd go around I would think
they would pay pensions
but if they're talking to Houston the
whole time but they don't know so and so
he would call her and it would be the
middle afternoon and she said literally
every time he called he would say what
you doing and she would say I'm at work
I'm doing the same thing that I'm doing
every day that you call me and I'm in
the middle of it and then he would say
well can I tell my dad a poor guy he
only had this other Russian dude to talk
to he needed to talk to somebody and
then he he said that he'd uh he'd call
his daughter and she'd be like well I'm
going to class dad and then she she
would she said that she literally did
the you're breaking up dad
thing where it was like trying to get
him off the phone she literally did that
to it right
poor guy up in space just well poor guy
up his face I mean the International
Space Station travels in orbit around
Earth at a speed of roughly 17,000 150
miles per hour that's about five miles
per second this means that the space
station orbits earth once every 92
minutes so it doesn't take long to go
100 I mean when he was out there in a
hundred and ninety days and he's been in
space 225 days total and you get patches
it's kind of like the Cub Scouts like
the Boy Scouts they got their patch game
is on fleek
he's got he got some patches well he has
a hundred day patch but he did not have
I was like where's the 208 that she was
I don't I don't have it even though he's
been out there 225 and needed a hundred
and ninety days in in sequence but
you're saying consecutively if you're
very selective about quarantine you
could colonize Mars or put set up base
there put it there brother to base on
the moon that's what one of the things
they want to do as basically a staging
area to get to Mars and other places so
you can have everyone working on the
International Space Station or this this
staging station on the moon or on Mars
in the future and you just eradicate
disease now well that of course it'll
find out what disease finds away but
you're quarantined and then you're
you're wearing that orange suit and
you're going out to the thing and I
think that's at that point you're
donating your
your eggs they donate that sperm right
before they take off because you need to
get your mind clear anyway no I don't
know how relaxing it is to donate an egg
that's true I think it's a lot more fun
to donate sperm than it is to donate
eggs
yeah probably difficulty easy you know
what we need to work on you and there's
a whole lot more to we can work on that
you do all that work and you get one egg
you get like a five billion sperm we got
it easy
yeah we've got to do this man
but we also have it it's easier for us
to use the bathroom we can stand true
but not in space face everybody's great
equalized everybody sits everybody sits
in space last night I got a diverge a
second cuz Lincoln comes in here and
then in the living room and he's like
Ida I wasn't the one who used a bathroom
all over the floor somebody sprayed all
over the floor Britain land Oh dad which
one of you guys splattered all over the
fungus Britain Orlando as if 200 and if
I had to narrow it down to one I would
say was Britain we all look at him and
then he he added he said I haven't used
the bathroom since I've gotten back I
was like I spent four hours back for
hours homie you're lying no I went in
the bathroom and we put in this we put
in black tile on the ground here's a hot
tip don't put black like matte-finish
tile in you're in a boy's bathroom
because you can see with the way the
lighting is right you can just see all
the splatter all bladder everywhere it's
like looking at a crime scene where the
serial killer used only urine right I
think there was a serial killer they
called him the PPP man killer
the pee pee sprayer Lincoln's like I was
first of all I was proud of him that he
was outraged about it even though I
still feel like maybe he did it
they call him the golden thing okay the
golden shower killer it's not the Golden
State well the Golden State what was it
guy's name Golden State Chris Mullin
I was trying come on I can't do it I
feel like the phlegm is constructing is
in construct constricting my ability to
direct tons obstructing I can't even
come up with right words you do not
astronaut material so I ended up making
Lando clean it up with a rag but I'm
just saying
hot tip no black floors in a boys boys
room and I was like guys I'm just
telling you you just need to sit down to
pee like the astronauts and me because
you never know it's very unpredictable
there's a lot of distance between John
Wayne spray see you got it uh I knew I'd
find it somewhere okay you found it that
was pretty good yeah John Wayne spray
see okay so back to astronauts okay so
we think they should be donating sperm
not to build a master race just to
supplement sperm banks just to up the
make people a little bit smarter I I
just don't think that they're big on
personality I'm not saying that I didn't
like him I didn't like the astronauts
that I met well they're not very
reactive yeah they're very they're so
even keel you can't be reactive you have
to be a non reactionary person I just
don't think that makes for a fun space
situation it's like when everybody's
unflappable you don't want if you're
saying you wanted to be like bachelor in
paradise up there you don't want that
I'm not you keep bringing it back to
like spread and seed and stuff no no no
I'm trying to make it about fun first of
all this is a clear indication to have
fun this is a clear indication that you
thought that my reference to bachelor in
paradise had to do something about what
to do with sex
yeah Jacob and Kiko clearly knew that I
just meant putting emotionally unstable
people together in a small space oh
that's why they both laughed because
reality television is about putting
emotionally unstable people together in
a confined space and that doesn't have
to be like a confined physical space but
it's just like confining them in some
way like you can only talk to these
people
so if you put those kind of people
together in the International Space
Station with alcohol with alcohol right
those people the whole state space
station would just somehow end up
getting burned up in the atmosphere it
wouldn't it just wouldn't it couldn't
succeed now but if we could all watch it
on television every Monday and Tuesday
night on ABC we would think it was worth
it but yeah you start colonizing places
you start to realize you think with the
I mean it's just not a fun place to it's
not a fun colony I'm just like it can't
be you event you can bring the fun
people later but having fun people do
the initial common point do I fun guy
get invited I don't know if you I never
get invited because I can't I'm too tall
for the spacecraft six four is the limit
yeah you're too tall
so I'll never I'll never go to I can do
maybe like the anti-gravity flight or
something like that but I can't
well maybe the the I might be able to
take a commercial flight maybe they'll
have some some option at some point but
another thing I want to talk about that
hit me when we were especially in the
space vehicle mock-up Center I was like
now I'm not a conspiracy theorist I know
I play one on good mythical morning from
time to time but I am NOT a conspiracy
theorist and Act theorist in actuality
and I do not believe that there's
compelling reasons to doubt that we have
been to the moon but I would but what I
would say is if I were a conspiracy
theorist
specifically this one who doubted that
the moon landing was real mm-hmm
I do not believe that taking a tour of
NASA would make me feel better I'm doing
here's what here's what I'll say going
into the space vehicle mock-up center
and seeing like the redneck centaur
you're like what is happening here like
I know that they're just experimenting
with different things but even if you
when you get inside the lunar module
which we stuck our heads in basically
the kind of contraption that's gonna go
up there you're like this all seems so
tenuous it just doesn't seem I know it's
a bunch of Engineers
and it's all well thought out but it
just seems like it could just innit of
course it times it has completely fallen
apart there's so many things that can go
wrong it just feels like I wouldn't have
a whole lot of confidence
it wasn't the type of environment that I
expected it to be like I would the fact
that we were like able to touch things
even though it was stuff that wasn't
gonna go in space it was this is the
mock-up center they don't let us touch
the real stuff but I just got this sense
that like man if I if I thought this was
fake and this was all just to carry out
carry on a lie
that's the quite an invalid probably
still believe it having seen this the
only way you could prove it to me if I
was a flat earther if I didn't believe
in the moon landing is you'd have to go
on the ride you know to go up I think
it's quite an investment to to to pull
the wool over the eyes of the public
to what end well yeah that's why
conspiracy theories
for the most part don't make sense
because when you're when fully analyzed
almost all conspiracy theories carrying
out the conspiracy theory becomes more
of a conspiracy than the conspiracy
theory itself and that's why most
conspiracy theories logically fall apart
but most people who most people who want
to believe conspiracy theories cannot be
swayed by logic or facts I think the
thing that I reacted to was that a lot
of it especially the experimental stuff
by design was like hey we're just we're
gonna see where this goes you know it's
this this spirit of exploration like
trudging towards a big question mark and
you know investing in the unknown we're
gonna we're gonna build this thing we're
gonna we're gonna have all these college
students compete to build all this
different type of stuff because they'll
probably come up with something that's
awesome that we'll need for something
else and you know they talk about all
the things you can look at the list of
all the things that we benefit from on
earth because they were byproducts of
all the innovation for space travel
but it is infectious to be there and to
see that it's just we set we looked up
and then we're like let's let's check it
out let's bend our will and then you
know you talk about people working
together like on the International Space
Station you got like the whole Russian
part you got the the Japanese built a
whole rec center for the freakin Space
Station a gym yeah they have the gym
module yeah it's a big one and it's and
you can and it's one of the only places
that you can send experiments out of the
International Space Station so it's not
just for push-ups in burpees you can do
you saying you can do like they send
experiments out there's like a little
happen to the elliptical outside of a
gas station well yeah like on the
Jetsons or it's like you got that
elliptical out there yeah walk the dog
on it but that spirit of exploration is
infectious and it was it was um I don't
know and it made me feel good about all
the stuff we try and we don't know why
we're doing it you know yeah yeah it to
me in our own little way it was like a
kinship and I know that people say that
a lot they're like why worry about this
when you've got you know you've got
people on earth who are not even getting
properly nude you know getting proper
nutrition well first of all I don't
think that it's a you know NetZero
situation so I don't think that it's not
a zero-sum game so if you if you invest
in space travel it necessarily means
someone's not getting a meal but I
completely agree with you that we should
be we should be trying things just to
try them it's like why I go like it
something like why go to Mars I mean we
have we're having trouble enough keeping
the inhabitable planet you know
habitable why we're going to go
someplace else that we're gonna have to
like Geoengineer this place just in in
order to live there I think it's because
you got to constantly be moving forward
and innovating you got a costly try
things there's sometimes people ask us
that question and I'm not gonna make a I
am gonna make it an analogy and I do not
think that what we do a mythical
entertainment is comparable to what is
happening at NASA even though they did
have that redneck that redneck centaur
which is yeah we had a thing totally on
the show we've gotten Paisley to build
one of those yeah but sometimes you're
like what are you like what are you
trying to do like what do you hope to do
why does why are you trying to keep
growing this night and to me a part of
it is just the thrill of discovery yeah
exploration it's just like a thrill of
expression and discover why am I gonna
throw this you know sodium into the
middle of a lake we're not gonna do that
no but there's there's like you know
they're like high school chemistry
teachers who will take like pure sodium
and throw it into the middle of a lake
to watch it explode I mean you can't do
that anymore but probably do it in the
80s and why do I do that because it's
like well it'd be cool to see that Lake
explosion I'm just saying sometimes you
just you you you start a process just to
see where it's gonna end I'm I'm all in
on space travel
I'm all in you gonna go I think gonna go
unless I have to
yeah I'm all in and going to the moon
going to Mars and I don't think I had to
have like a why beyond just because
let's see if we can do it as people
let's see if we can do it as a
civilization yeah well so if Fred ever
goes up we can credit that little tour
we took right he's gonna be he's gonna
be gripping lovingly to a to a centaur
Rover cuz I'm not gonna be there I'm
gonna be John Wayne Spacey the puns keep
coming all right I'm gonna look up my
rack because I got it here in a you know
you know let's see are you ready for my
wreck yeah wreck baby wreck baby 1 2 3 4
wreck baby wreck baby Oh
right I'm gonna recommend the sleep
headphones bluetooth 5.0 Wireless I'm
asked recently featured in the Rhett MC
Instagram yeah our friend Jenny she
knows I'm big into like sleep masks and
she brought one I had a party she
brought one over I was like you expect
this party's gonna be this bad you're
gonna be sleep masking it up in the
corner she's like no I wanted you to see
this because I knew you'd be into it
because on the bus oh maybe she heard me
complaining that like I had a really
good sleep mask within I put my earbuds
in and if you sleep on your side like
crams them into your ears and you're
trying to listen to the deep sleep
playlist this solves that problem
the only thing it doesn't have is noise
cancelling and you have to jack up the
volume all the way when you're on a tour
bus because it's a because it can't do
the noise canceling unless it has
something in your ear canal right yeah
the problem because this is like oh it's
different technology - well because I
felt those and there was no I couldn't
tell you where the speakers there's
little speakers right over your ears but
if you lay on your side it does feel
like you're just laying on plush
headband and I mean not a sponsor of
course that's only 20 bucks and it
connects Bluetooth to hydrated 775
reviews four and a half stars yeah well
that's very I just think I don't yeah as
I mean it's not 20 but I use it on the
plane yes only 20 bucks yeah you think
it'd be more than that so yeah that's my
wreck man again home dur hom D er what
do you recommend wearing it with a hat
and a bandanna on flights and looking
like Darth Vader
yeah the guy beside me who I did not
know had to have had to have been into
it I'm sure he loved it I've got to say
I'm gonna continue taking pictures of
you while you fly just know the mouth is
open underneath the bandana yeah is it
definitely right definitely that's why I
do that cuz I don't I don't really care
about the picture but I just don't like
the idea of breathing in peoples
without my filter yeah or looking or
putting stuff in my mouth yeah people
have been known to do that people could
do that yeah but not now with my bandana
I also recommend a bandana over your
face so there you have it I am glad that
we were here and that we did this don't
get me wrong it's not that I I got I
picked up a little I wanted to take a
nap but so what
yeah thanks for hanging out amps needed
hopefully you didn't nap through this
hashtag ear biscuits will speak at you
again next week to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]